[Musique]
malo maury quam fouet dari je préfère
mourir qu'être déshonorait telle est la
devise d'anne de bretagne brillante
duchesse habile négociatrice et
redoutable esprit politique dont la
destinée singulière la conduite au
sommet de l'état et la consacre deux
fois reine de france anne de bretagne si
on veut être honnête on a très très peu
de choses peu de témoignages directs
essentiellement une image là encore
iconographiques ou littéraires mais
excessivement élogieuses me faisant
d'elle une nouvelle vierge d'une arène
de vertu une très française règne de
france après la terrible guerre de cent
ans
achevé en 14 253 qui a divisé les
allégeances en opposant la france des
valois à sa grande rivale l'angleterre
gouverné par les plantagenêts plusieurs
princes d'europe rêve désormais
d'annexer la précieuse bretagne enjeu
stratégique majeur dans l'équilibré des
pouvoirs
[Musique]
le futur mariage de la petite duchesse
héritière devient donc le centre de
toutes les attentions et de tous les
calculs politiques
elle ne ménage pas ses efforts pour
conserver l'autonomie de son duché
ce n'est qu'au terme de la guerre folle
en 14 100 88 puis un conflit sanglant
opposant l'insoumise duchesse à
l'autorité du roi de france cannes de
bretagne fini par se résoudre à
l'impensable épousé son ennemi intime 20
chars le 8 ou 14 180 devenue veuve sans
avoir pu donner d'héritier mâle la
couronne et conformément à son premier
contrat de mariage
anne de bretagne est obligée d'épouser
en 14 999 le successeur du défunt roi
louis d'orléans
ce dernier ancien allié de la guerre
folle accède au trône sous le nom de
louis xii et permettent à son épouse de
le seconde et dans l'exercice du pouvoir
mais ça prouve aussi l'importance
politique qu'elle avait en tant
qu'héritière du dessus du duché de
bretagne mécènes et femme d'esprit
maintien d'une cour brillante et
installe les femmes dans de hautes
fonctions d'ordinaire réservé aux hommes
[Musique]
anne de bretagne nord le 9 janvier 15 à
elle transmet son d'héritage breton à sa
fille claude
mariée au fougueux françois 1er qui va
sceller en 15 132 l'irrémédiable fin de
l'indépendance de la péninsule
[Musique]
anne de bretagne
né le 25 janvier 14 177 au château de
nantes fille de marguerite deux fois et
du duc françois ii de bretagne elle est
l'héritière d'une prestigieuse lignée
qui règne sur le duché depuis treize 165
après avoir résisté aux invasions
vikings et franck les bretons construire
un véritable état dont les frontières
s'étendent de la vendée au cotentin
depuis le règne de nominaux et leur tout
premier souffre à ans 939 le royaume
devient un duché souverain et
indépendant dont l'importance
géostratégique suscite autant les
convoitises de la france que celle de
son ennemi juré
l'angleterre en pleine guerre de cent
ans de 13 cents 37 à 14 253 et de
puissances rivales vont chercher à
imposer leur hégémonie sur la péninsule
en favorisant la candidature de leurs
proches à la couronne du cad
entre 141 la mort du duc jean 300
postérité plonge le duché de bretagne
vassal du roi de france dans une sombre
guerre de succession
deux familles rivales les penthièvre et
les montfort se disputent alors
l'héritage pendant près de 23 ans
charles de blois époux de jeanne de
penthièvre et jean de montfort
revendiquent tous deux la succession
dans un climat de guerre franco anglaise
extrêmement tendue
chacun se hâtent de nouer des alliances
pour parvenir à ses fins
non
jean de montfort s'empresse de prêter
l'hommage lige au roi d'angleterre
edouard iii
ce dernier s'est auto proclamé roi de
france en vertu de sa filiation avec le
défunt roi philippe iv le bel dont il
est le petit-fils par sa mère isabelle
de france ils considèrent donc levallois
philippe six issus de la branche cadette
de la dynastie capétienne au pouvoir
depuis treize 128 comme un usurpateur
charles de blois choisi quant à lui le
camp des français
il se rallie ainsi au roi philippe si ce
qui n'est autre que son oncle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la victoire anglaise à auray en 13 164
met un terme à la guerre de succession
de bretagne et permet la signature du
premier traité de guérande le 12 avril
13 165 jean de montfort est alors
reconnu comme l'héritier légitime du
duché de bretagne sous le nom de jean iv
aussitôt le duc s'allie avec
l'angleterre afin d'éviter tout nouveau
conflit de succession
le traité prévoit la transmission du
duché d'héritier mâle à héritiers mâles
dans la famille de montfort et en cas
d'absence de descendance il devra passer
aux mâles de la maison de penthièvre à
défaut d'héritier mâle des deux côtés le
gouvernement du duché sera alors dévolu
aux femmes
françois de bretagne petit fils de jean
iv accède à la couronne ducale en 14 158
anglophile comme ses prédécesseurs il
s'emploie à maintenir l'indépendance de
la bretagne vis-à-vis des grandes
puissances qui la convoitent en
particulier la france leduc n'ayant pas
eu deux fils la perspective du mariage
de sa fille aînée and devient rapidement
l'objet de toutes les convoitises
la petite duchesse et éduquer pour
gouverner car contrairement aux
princesses de france soigneusement tenue
à l'écart des affaires du royaume la loi
salique n'existe pas en bretagne
destinée à devenir une tête politique
prêt à se battre pour les intérêts
bretons anne est initié par les plus
brillants conseiller de son père et
assistent aux séances du conseil du cal
la bretagne est un pays grâce à sa
langue et ses coutumes
elle jouit d'une organisation comparable
à celle de la france possède son armée
son clergé son parlement et sa propre
chance elle rit sous la houlette du
chancelier dont le rôle est comparable à
celui d'un principal ministre
la chancellerie et l'institution
centrale qui régit l'administration du
duché
face à l'autoritarisme du nouveau roi de
france louis 11 françois deux va prendre
part à nombre de soulèvements qui vont
le conduire à signer des traités
désavantageux pour la bretagne
[Musique]
louis 11 règne sur la france de 14 161 à
14 100 83
celui qu'on surnomme le prudent où il a
régné gouverne par la ruse autant que
par les armes
un programme politique qu'il assume
pleinement par ces mots a valeur de
préceptes qui ne s'est dissimulé ne
s'est pas renier il s'attache à
manipuler tantôt en achetant en
séduisant tantôt en menaçant et en
brutalisant ce grand pragmatique ne
croit pas à l'efficacité de la plume et
du pinceau pour tenir les zones pour
tenir les esprits pour lui ce qui
importe c'est de tenir les corps et pour
ça rien de voleur et le faire des armes
on achète on compte hier on ne lasse on
soumet ce sont les fondements de sa
politique
[Musique]
il hérite d'un royaume exergue à
l'économie dévastée
épuisé par la guerre de cent ans et les
pillages successifs
on a parlé d'un four d'un intrigant
personnage extrêmement cruelle en
réalité ce portrait était sans doute à
nuancer c'est quelqu'un qui a fait
l'apprentissage du métier de roi
de façon assez longue dans les missions
que lui avait confié son père charles
vii
il a régné sur le dauphiné c'était un
personnage qui avait appris l'art de
gouverner et qui effectivement était
certainement froidure
mais c'était un grand capitaine louis 11
lutte pour unifier les provinces à
grandir et organiser le royaume
conditions nécessaires à un
développement économique rapide
il entend pour cela mettre au pas le
clergé et les grands féodaux pour un
excellent et du chai autonome rebelles à
son royaume il s'acharne à combattre
charles le téméraire puissant ducs de
bourgogne dans une guerre sans merci qui
va rapporter à la france la bourgogne
l'artois et la picardie
[Musique]
l'acquisition du roussillon du maine
anjou et de la provence relève de cette
fameuse politique toujours aussi fine qu
efficace qui reste l'apanage de la bile
s'ouvre à lui 11 tisse la toile france
qui à la fin de son règne ressemble déjà
beaucoup à la carte de la france
actuelle
en 14 165 la ligue du bien public
unis le frère du roi charles ii france
au prince des maisons de bretagne
d'anjou d'albret d'armagnac et de
bourdon qui entendent préserver leurs
prérogatives face aux pouvoirs gros 10
en 2011
[Applaudissements]
c'est juillet 14 165 les armées rivales
s'affrontent à montlhéry sans désigner
véritablement de vainqueur pourtant
louis ans préfère négocier cette guerre
se solde par le traité de conflans le 5
octobre 14 à 165 qui cède le duché de
normandie en apanage à charles de france
mais nombre à geloux et 11 ne pardonne
pas à françois 2 d'avoir bafoué son
autorité à l'automne 14 167 il fait
ravagé les marches de bretagne sont ceux
liés guillaume chauvin signe la
capitulation du duché à ancenis de 10
septembre 14 soit 168 ce traité oblige
le duc à rompre l'alliance avec
l'angleterre et charles le téméraire
pourtant dès 14h 172 françois 2 qui
souhaitent maintenir l'indépendance du
duché de bretagne
ça soulève de nouveau contre le roi de
france
abandonné par ses alliés anglais et
bourguignons il est contraint de signer
la paix de senlis le 9 octobre 14 275
qui resserre les liens entre la france
et la bretagne font soit 2 fait
allégeance au roi louis ix 11 et
s'engage désormais à le soutenir dans
ses guerres
il laisse un royaume puissant redouté de
ses voisins un royaume où à l'intérieur
l'autorité royale est très forte et
incontesté toute opposition
aristocratique a été brisée mais il
laisse aussi un royaume souffrent car
ces résultats spectaculaires ont été
atteints au prix d'une flambée des
impôts qui écrase les français alors
même que les dernières années du règne
sont marquées par une succession de cas
d'amité naturel et d'épidémies en
définitive on peut dire que le roi louis
ix on laisse une france grande et des
français malheureux
[Musique]
m
charles de 8 n'est le 30 juin 14 166 au
château d'amboise
il est le seul fils du roi louis ix 11
et de la reine charlotte de savoie il a
cependant deux soeurs plus âgés jeunes
de france et anne de france qui vont
elles aussi jouer un rôle très
particulier
selon la volonté du roi coop le futur
charles wuyts voit le jour
son père son papa lou lyon est déjà un
vieux monsieur et sa maman est une
vieille dame charlotte de savoir parce
que cet enfant mener au bout de 34 ans
de mariage lyon qui se soucie enfin de
son fils au terme de sa vie vannes
instruire et d'utiliser à des fins
politiques
au gré de promesses de mariage qui
n'aboutiront pas il était de santé
fragile
l'oms qui veillait sur lui comme sur la
prunelle de ses yeux évidemment car
c'était l'héritier de la couronne de
cette france qu'il avait forgé louis 11
patiemment lentement sans faire de
guerre au très peu eh bien il lui dit
non tu n'apprends pas le latin ça sert à
rien repose-toi veille sur la santé et
le charlot 8 va vivre et va régner le 30
mai 14 284 charles 8 est armé chevalier
est couronné roi de france en la
cathédrale de reims avec tous les
honneurs et apparat qui conviennent à un
grand personnage d'europe
mais charles est encore trop jeune pour
gouverner seul avant de mourir le 30
août 14 183 louis 11 désigne sa fille
anne de france plus connu sous le nom
d'anne de beaujeu pour veiller sur le
jeune charlie 8 et conduire avec lui les
affaires du royaume et devient roi très
jeunes présents et il est complètement
sous tutelle de la régente désigné par
louis 11 avalisé par les états généraux
qui est anne de beaujeu al de france
comme de beaux jeux
c'est la fille aînée survivante de louis
oms comme lui c'est une tête politique
et elle va avec son mari pierre de
bourbon le cir de beau jeu dont le rôle
politique a été sous-estimée par
beaucoup d'historiens prendre la tête du
parti des héritiers politiques de louis
oms
elle va s'attacher à maintenir l'oeuvre
de son père la fille ont laquelle louis
11 à une parfaite confiance et à
laquelle il voue une admiration sans
borne va donc assurer une régence plutôt
brillante de 14 à 181 3 à 14 100 91
mais la haute noblesse conteste la
légitimité de cette gouvernance louis
d'orléans le futur louis xii est le
successeur de charles ix 8
si celui ci décède ou s'il n'a pas
d'héritier mâle
de surcroît il est marié à l'une des
filles de louis aux jeunes de france
surnommé l' estropiés ce mariage très
politique est initiée par le rusé roi
défunt pour intégrer le duché d'orléans
au royaume de france
le nom orléans et donnait à la branche
cadette
ils sont à la fois descendants des
capétiens apparenté à la branche
régnante est considéré quand même comme
des rivaux dangereux par cette branche
régnante en 14 176 alors que louis n'a
que 14 ans le roi fait célébrer cette
union est croyant sa fille stérile ils
pensaient les l'extinction de la branche
rival d'orléans
chacun des époux retourne ensuite à ses
occupations louis mène bien tout une vie
de plaisirs et de débauche
tandis que jane se consacre à la prière
et aux oeuvres charitables les après la
mort de louis 11 louis d'orléans à
d'autres solutions
le parti aristocratique redresse
aussitôt la tête est uni autour du jeune
duc d'orléans louis d'orléans qui va
revendiquer pour lui-même la tutelle du
roi et le gouvernement du royaume comme
ils n'arrivent pas à l'obtenir il va
leur réclamer la convocation des états
généraux pour trancher cette question
politique de première importance
et comme nous sommes à ce moment dans un
contexte de réaction inévitable après
l'autoritarisme du règne précédent
les beaux jeux sont obligés d'accepter
mais ils vont prendre un certain nombre
de précautions et en particulier pour la
première fois on va organiser de
véritables élections pour envoyer des
députés et les beaux jeux vont
s'arranger pour un bon nombre de ses
députés soient des officiers royaux
attachés à l'état royal à l'oeuvre du
défunt roi et à leurs services and on
lève l'adhésion des états généraux
réunis à tours en 14 184 à l'initiative
de louis d'orléans
usant de compromis confie à ce dernier
la présidence du conseil royal en
imposant une présence constante d'elle
et de son mari pierre de beaujeu ducs de
bourbons auprès de charles ou huit
louis ne tarde pas à comprendre la
supercherie et entre en rébellion
entraînant avec lui quelques grands du
royaume il se réfugie chez le duc
françois ii de bretagne déclenchant un
conflit qui va porter le nom de guerre
folle
114 284 la bretagne se retrouve de
nouveau au centre d'un conflit de
succession alors que le traité de
guérande signé en 13 à 165 devait en
principe éviter toute ambiguïté un
problème inédit se posent à la fin du
règne de françois 2 leduc pas que deux
filles anne isabeau et les descendants
penthièvre sont également des femmes le
roi de france charles 8 fait alors jouer
ses droits sur le duché
en effet en 14 980 son père le rusé roi
louis ix 11
après le son de racheter les droits de
succession de la comtesse de penthièvre
14 284 par un traité signé à montargis
cinq seniors bretons se retourne contre
françois 2 et reconnaissent charlie 8
comme l'héritier légitime de bretagne
deux camps s'opposent donc pour la
succession à la couronne ducale l'un
favorable au duc françois ii et l'autre
au roi de france françois 2 s'empresse
alors de faire reconnaître sa fille anne
déjà titré duchesse par les états de
bretagne et de la promettre au prince
edward fils du roi d'angleterre
le contexte demeure donc explosif entre
la france et son indomptable vassal
breton anne de beaujeu perçoit alors
dans le soutien du duc françois ii ou
rebelle louis ii d'orléans l'occasion
rêvée de réaliser une subtile opération
d'agrandissement du royaume de france
la guerre folle qui comprendra plusieurs
épisodes au fil des années 1480 et qui
fait écho à la guerre du bien public
s'ouvre lyon est une tentative de
l'opposition aristocratique pour prendre
par les armes le contrôle du royaume et
de la personne royale
c'est l'expression d'un chroniqueur kiné
qui parle d'une guerre en fait une
guerre sans espoir parce que c'est
toujours la même
la même histoire qui recommence ce sont
les grands féodaux qui s'opposent au
pouvoir royal comme on l'a vu avec louis
11 au moment de la pra grillé comme on
le reverra après avec la fronde sous
louis xiv et il ya beaucoup d'autres
moments de l'histoire parmi royal
commandé par louis 2 de la trémoille
s'opposent à l'armée bretonne du
maréchal de rieux au printemps 14 187
les français occupent ancenis et
châteaubriant il marche est ensuite sur
ploërmel puis sur vannes contraignant
françois ii à se replier à nantes après
sept semaines de siège les bretons
parviennent à repousser de roi les
hostilités reprennent de plus belle au
printemps 14 à 181 8 en mai charlot 8
contrôler la frontière entre la bretagne
et l'anjou de châteaubriant au loroux
bottereau
la trémoille entend verrouiller le nord
de la bretagne conduisant une armée de
15000 hommes verts fouchères
[Musique]
l'artillerie foudroie la ville qui
capitule de 19 juillet 14 188
c'est à 20 km de là le 28 juillet 14 188
dans la ville de saint-aubin-du-cormier
que se déroule la grande bataille de la
guerre folle malgré l'héroïsme de
l'armée bretonne qui conserve l'avantagé
au début du conflit
louis d'orléans et les féodaux rebelles
sont faits prisonniers
[Musique]
françois de les vaincus il est contraint
de signer le traité du verger des 19 et
20 août 14 188 qui confirme la
suprématie de la france sur la bretagne
le duc doit l'hommage lige au roi de
france et laisse quatre places fortes en
garantie saint-aubin-du-cormier dinan
fougères et saint malo
une clause stipule aussi qu'il ne pourra
marier ses filles sans le consentement
de charlot 8
anne de beaujeu soucieuse du devenir du
puissant duché de bretagne veut que
cessent les relations commerciales et
stratégiques que la péninsule entretient
depuis toujours avec l'angleterre
elle attend patiemment le moment propice
qui ne tarde pas à survenir
[Musique]
à la mort du duc de bretagne le 9
septembre 14 288 sa fille anne devient
officiellement duchesse elle porte donc
en elle
l'avenir du très convoité du che et va
s'employer à préserver l'oeuvre
d'autonomie de ses prédécesseurs afin
d'obtenir le soutien militaire de l'
empire et les pouces maximilien
d'autriche par procuration le 19
décembre 14 190 sans le consentement du
roi de france
cet acte sonne comme une violation du
traité du verger et la régente anne de
beaujeu ne compte pas en rester là elle
va décider doigt tel point même que elle
va lever des armées pour aller jusqu'à
rennes pour s'emparer de rennes avec le
petit charles witt la région fait
immédiatement marché ses troupes sur la
bretagne la duchesse c'est qu'elle n'a
pas les moyens de résister à l'armée
royale et il va devoir se résoudre à
l'impensable
finalement la seule option frêle
enviable la plus satisfaisante pour les
intérêts du royaume de france c'est que
la duchesse anne épouse charles wuyts
lui même mais se poser problème parce
que charles wuyts ancêtre marié à
marguerite de bourgogne anne de france
la dame de beau jeu est elle-même
réticente face à cette solution parce
qu'elle est elle l avait été partisans
du mariage avec marguerite de bourgogne
mais elle finit par se plier à la raison
d'état et part déclaré elle-même que
c'est la meilleure solution pour
pacifier le royaume
le 6 décembre 14 à 191 anne de bretagne
épouse officiellement charles 8 au
château de langeais les injonctions de
l'autriche auprès de la papauté restent
vaines et innocent 8 valide sans
rechigner en lentilles datant l'union du
roi de france et de la duchesse de
bretagne
[Musique]
c'est le jour du mariage que la finesse
politique et la vision à long terme
d'anne de beaujeu atteignent des sommets
elle fait ajouter au contrat de mariage
une clause d'importance capitale
en cas d'absence d'héritier mâle la
duchesse de bretagne ne pourra se
remarier qu'avec le successeur du roi de
france
par ce traité très dur pour la duchesse
elle doit céder à charles 8 les droits
qu'elle tient de son père sur le duché
de bretagne elle devient reine de france
mais elle perd le titre de duchesse de
bretagne elle perd l'administration du
duché continue elle à posséder la
bretagne et louis charles louis de ton
petit peu pour la baule le prince
consort en quelque sorte qu'il n'est pas
il n'est pas dupe ni roi de bretagne ni
quoi que ce soit et elle doit accepter
au cas où son mari mort est le premier
sans héritier de n'épousez aucun autre
que le futur roi de france les clauses
de ce contrat de mariage sont vraiment
destiné à s'assurer que la bretagne quoi
qu'il advienne n'échappera plus à la
couronne de france et elle va d'ailleurs
après son mariage quitté la bretagne
pour la cour de france et n'y remettra
plus les pieds du vivant de son mari
anne de bretagne et sacré à saint denis
le 8 février 14 192 grand est rarissime
honneur pour une reine de france
duchesse désormais sous tutelle
elle cesse d'administrer ses états elle
pèse pourtant de toute son autorité en
obtenant que ces officiers soit maintenu
dans leurs charges
le roi de france s'engage aussi
publiquement à respecter les coutumes et
des libertés bretonne en matière
d'impôts et de justice
la reine tient une cour brillante et
installe des femmes dans de hautes
fonctions d'ordinaire réservé aux hommes
elles seconde efficacement son époux
parti guerroyer en italie en 14 294 dans
l'espoir de se tailler un royaume à
nabeul dans l'héritage de son père louis
aux charlots 8 trouvent les biens de du
bon roi rené d'anjou et rené d'anjou
avait eu par une une tante jeanne jeanne
de naples avait le royaume de naples en
héritage alors charles de 8 10 bompas
sait très bien ce royaume de naples
m'appartient et je vais aller le
chercher et ils se lancent dans cette
première campagne militaire vers
l'italie parce que l'italie où il va le
découvrir est un pays richissime
merveilleux couvert de monuments
fantastique plein d'artistes
brillantissime en partant en italie pour
récupérer son royaume de naples
charlot 8 va quand même ouvrir la porte
à cinquante années de guerre franco
italienne gracié par charlot 8 louis
d'orléans accompagne le roi en italie
ses cousins valois du rameau d'orléans
espère alors prendre le contrôle du
duché de milan
ils estiment avoir des droits sur ce
territoire dans la mesure où sa
grand-mère valentine visconti était la
fille de jean gallice visconti seigneur
de milan et d'isabelle de france
l'europe à cette époque a profondément
changé pour la france l'ennemi n'est
plus le roi d'angleterre qui ne possède
plus que calais b maximilien d'autriche
mais guère l'italie marque ainsi le
début de l'affrontement forcené entre
valois et habsburg ces derniers vont
bientôt prendre possession de l'espagne
et tente d'unifier leurs empires en
s'emparant de l'italie les français se
trouveraient alors encerclé par la
puissance autrichienne
l'italie plus prosaïquement c'est à
l'époque le champ clos des rivalités
entre les grandes puissances européennes
il y a en particulier l'aragon donc la
couronne d'aragon il y a l' empire g
manik dont l'italie du nord fait
toujours formellement partie et dans ces
conditions le roi de france ne peut pas
abandonner la scène italienne sont
perdre de son prestige sur la scène
européenne
[Musique]
la victoire de charles 8 et son
occupation du sud de l'italie inquiète
la noblesse et les monarques européens
qui décident de réagir
la ligue de venise se constituer en 1495
pour faire face au danger que représente
aux yeux de ses membres les ambitions de
charlot 8 qui vient de conquérir le
royaume de naples
elle est animée par la république de
venise et comprend également le duché de
milan ainsi que deux acteurs extérieurs
à la péninsule italienne qui sont
l'empereur et le roi d'aragon
cette coalition force charlie 8 a amorcé
la retraite française
le futur louis xii reste lui à nos
arrêts hélas pour lui il va se retrouver
encerclés à siéger et il va le voir
s'enfuir dans les conditions absolument
misérable est rentré en france et il
repartira plus tard en campagne d'italie
mais la première campagne pour lui s'est
mal terminée après la défaite de novare
et la victoire miraculeuse à fort nous
lui permet de sauver l'honneur
cette victoire et le départ du roi ouvre
la voie à la reconquête totale du
royaume de naples sur les français qui
est parachevée en 1497
leroy rentrer en france l'esprit encore
imprégné de rêves de conquête italienne
et retrouve son épouse le rôle principal
dan se joue alors sur un tout autre
terrain
elle doit donner un dauphin à la france
arena couche le 10 octobre 14 192 dans
garçons charles orlan qui meurent de la
rougeole en décembre à 14 995 elle perd
un autre fils nés avant terme en août 14
à 193 une fille mort né au printemps 14
995 un garçon à un mois en 14 à 196 et
une dernière fille
peu après sa naissance en mars 14 198
ces drames afflige profondément le
couple royal
charlot 8 dès son retour d'italie décide
de réformer sa vie privée et de se
réfugier dans la prière et la chasteté
il subit sans nul doute l' influence de
son confident françois de paule et fait
expulser toutes les filles de joie de la
cour au grand dam des courtisans
contrairement à son illustre grand-père
charles vii qui était fou d'amour pour
la belle agnès sorel il n'a pas imposé
de favorite à la cour anne au caractère
bien trempé exclusive capricieuse et
extrêmement pieuse n'aurait su tolérer
cette pratique humiliante hellemmes
leroy sincèrement sans doute grâce à sa
légendaire amabilité et sa grande
générosité de coeur le 7 avril
1498 chars le 8è dans son beau et
nouveau château d'amboise et après
déjeuner il rend visite à la reine anne
de bretagne dans ses appartements
la reine vient de perdre un enfant
prématuré et le roi pour lui changer les
idées lui propose de l'emmener voir une
partie de jeu de paume dans les fossés
du château en la précédent dans un
escalier il va heurter du front une
porte
[Musique]
il assiste à la partie mais à la fin de
celle ci deux souverains s'écroule dans
les bras de son confesseur après neuf
heures de commun entre coupé de bref
retour de la parole leroy rend l'âme
plongeon la reine dans un état de grande
et sincère détresse anne de bretagne
semble avoir été très affecté par la
mort de son mari
ce mari qui lui avait été imposée et
qu'elle avait fini par aimer sincèrement
à ce qu'il semble
charles ou huit derniers valois direct
meurt sans héritier de 7 avril 14 198
son cousin louis d'orléans lui succèdent
sous le nom de louis dose anne de
bretagne prend l'initiative de
l'originalité et du gigantisme du
tombeau de son époux à saint denis
elle assume ainsi jusqu'au bout son rôle
de femme politique au service de son roi
dans l'ensemble on peut dire que sous le
règne de charles ix 8 le royaume
continue sa convalescence et le fait
même que le roi et puis s'absenter
longuement du royaume sans soubresauts
majeurs montre bien la maturité
politique atteinte par l'état royal et
la stabilité que les beaux jeux et
charles vite ont su conserver
l'oeuvre de charles vite reste inachevée
la france est ruinée par le coût
démesuré de la guerre d'italie mais leur
attachement de la précieuse bretagne est
en bonne voie
la renaissance dans charlot 8 est sans
conteste d'initiateur va donner un
souffle nouveau à la politique et
asseoir le formidable rayonnement
artistique de la france dans toute
l'europe
[Musique]
on
seule la raison d'état compte c'est le
trait principal du caractère obstiné de
la duchesse de bretagne
conformément au contrat de mariage 2491
elle va épouser le nouveau roi de france
et nouveau roi de france n'est autre que
le duc d'orléans son ancien allié qui
est devenu le roi louis xii et le duc
d'orléans
c'est un descendant de charles 5 l'un
des petit-fils de charles 5 donc on
reste dans l'est dans les dents les à
l'oise est toujours dans la même famille
et descendants du roi charles 5
louis xii s'empresse de faire annuler
par le sulfureux pape alexandre vi
borgia son mariage avec jeanne de france
sous prétexte qu'il n'a pas été consommé
jeanne a quand même donné son avis l ai
dit je sais bien que je ne suis pas très
joli mais mon mariage a tout de même été
consommés en réalité ces protestations
n'ont servi à rien anne épouse le roi
louis xii le 8 janvier 14 999 et devient
reine de france pour la seconde fois il
épouse donc la duchesse anne
mais avec des conditions beaucoup plus
favorables que dans le premier contrat
de mariage
cette fois ci la reine ne s'efface pas
derrière son époux qui est un ancien
allié de la guerre folle et elle négocie
habilement les clauses de ce contrat
elle retrouve son titre de duchesse de
bretagne
elle retrouve ses droits sur le duché de
bretagne et l'administration du duché
[Musique]
le couple royal vite à blois one va
apposer sa marque 1 à sculpter et
l'hermine emblème des ducs de bretagne
la reine est cultivé et apprécient l'art
italien
elle a pratiqué un mécénat assez
intéressant assez important je ne pense
pas du tout et ça ça s'avère en tout cas
par rapport à d'autres recherches
qu'elle connaissait le latin l'hébreu ou
les langues européennes de l'époque
comme on a pu le dire
quelquefois quand à son sa personnalité
réelle c'était une femme là aussi
peut-être beaucoup plus dur qu'on ne
peut l'imaginer mais par rapport à une
morale c'est une femme très pieuse elle
pas par contre est qui qui a un gros
souci de cette morale est la condition
d'une femme à l'intérieur de d'un cercle
familial
à 35 ans louis xii montre dès le début
son désir de réconciliation par ses
célèbres mots le roi de france ne venge
pas les injures faites au duc d'orléans
l'histoire retiendra son surnom de père
du peuple
lorsqu'on est assis sur le trône le plus
élevé eh bien on doit oublier toutes les
mesquineries on ne doit pas se venger de
toutes les avanies que l'on n'a reçu sur
le chemin du pouvoir
louis xii hérite des droits des valois
sur le royaume de naples et convoite
également milan louis xii va reprendre
cette politique expansionniste va pas
aller directement à naples il va aller à
milan milan c'est plus rapide il ya
moins de problèmes de diplomatie et puis
c'est surtout parce qu'il a des droits
à cause de sa grand-mère valentine
visconti milan et un duché gouverné par
le célèbre chef de guerre et grands
mécènes
ludovic sforza surnommé de mort ce
prince italien qui avait le tort d'être
trop riche trop beau trop associé à
l'image artistique dont rêvait les
princes français a connu une fin un peu
triste dans un château français
[Musique]
ludovic sforza meurt en captivité au
château de loches 27 mai 15 au 108
si la première tentative de conquête de
milan est un échec la seconde est une
véritable réussite gènes se donne aussi
du coup au roi de france qui déjà une
vie aussi l'île de corse c'est un
territoire qui devient de plus en plus
important
[Musique]
tous
oui
[Musique]
louis xii s'allie avec leroy finit dans
deux tarragon pour conquérir le royaume
de bab
[Musique]
le nouveau pape jules ii 2 d'abord
favorable aux français entend consolider
son pouvoir sur la péninsule italienne
et renforcer l'union fragile des états
pontificaux
il craint de ce fait la puissance
grandissante de louis xii qui vient
d'écraser les vénitiens à la bataille
dania d'elle le 14 mai qu'un ce sang
neuf jules ii a très vite montré ses
ambitions et a eu peur de plus en plus
de cette puissance française et donc en
15 100 9 après la victoire de louis xii
contre les vénitiens et qui faisait de
louis xii le prince le plus puissant
d'europe
eh bien il va créer une ligue à sainte
ligue contre le roi de france et a mené
tous les ennemis du roi de france avec
lui pour chasser louis xii et d'italie à
partir de là les français vont perdre
peu à peu tous les territoires qu'ils
avaient conquis
[Musique]
c'est françois 1er qui poursuivra
l'aventuré
soucieux lui aussi de regagner
l'héritage de valentine visconti simoun
aux repères le royaume de naples au bout
de deux ans enfin sa partie du royaume
de naples le duché de milan et de la
république de gênes il va la conserver
pratiquement pendant tout son règne et
cette domination pendant près de 15 ans
de ces territoires vont apporter
énormément d'argent à la france et c'est
ce qui va permettre à louis do justement
d'être habité une politique plus l'impôt
plus modérée en français les italiens
payant toutes les guerres
[Musique]
il
louis xii est quelqu'un qui a compté
dans l'histoire comme un roi modéré
tolérant et en même temps chef de guerre
puisqu'il a eu l'expédition italienne
qui ont plus ou moins rapporter à la
france
il se lève à les dresser un portrait
catastrophique en le traitant de vieux
d'imbéciles de malades c'est une île de
tous complètement gouverné par part
c'est par son entourage notamment
justement d'anne de bretagne qui serait
devenu plus bretonne encore et qu'il
cherchait qu'à qu'à détruire la
politique du royaume est un homme
complètement soumis à sa femme ça c'est
très très très mauvais au 19e et donc et
l'image de louis xii va jamais se
relever tout ça ça va être repris
puisque j'ai parlé des michelet sont
quelquefois parole d'évangile pour
certains auteurs et ça va être pris
pendant un siècle et humiliée pendant un
siècle et demi ce sera un roi médiocre
un roi sans aucun intérêt et aujourd'hui
depuis quelques années en tout cas on
cherche un peu à retravailler sur ses
personnages et on en découvre toutes les
finesses août la grandeur toute
l'intelligence symbole du souverain
modéré encensé par les révolutionnaires
si laura de louis xii surnommé le père
du peuple a pâli depuis le 19e siècle
n'en reste pas moins le roi avisés d'une
époque charnière de l'histoire de france
ce son règne le rôle des femmes
commencent à changer
la reine elle-même tête politique
secondes son époux dans l'exercice du
pouvoir
elle s'entoure de jeunes femmes de bonne
naissance qui brille bientôt par l'éclat
de leur intelligence leur mari
comprennent alors que les qualités de
leurs épouses peuvent leur attribuer
davantage de crédits dans la société
ainsi l'exemple du couple royal
permet-il à l'autre moitié du monde
d'accéder à une certaine reconnaissance
le
la reine c'est aussi se montrer
impitoyable à l'encontre des proches
conseillers de louis xii
elle soutient le cardinal d'amboise
contre son ennemi juré
pierre de rohan le maréchal de gier ce
dernier est le bras armé du souverain et
sa puissance militaire inquiète anne de
bretagne qui décident de réagir et bien
une cabale va commencer à se créer et
des rumeurs ont circulé comme quoi agier
auraient été susceptibles de s'y louis
xii était décédé et il était à l'époque
malades et bien d'interdire anne de
bretagne de repartir sur nantes
c'est une rumeur rien d'autre même si
cette rumeur va dans l'historiographie
après devenir faits et réalités
mais ça c'est une autre histoire et bien
cette rumeur va va grossir de plus en
plus certains vont être choqués et anne
de bretagne louise de savoie et georges
d'amboise qui étaient tous intéressés
par la régence possible en cas de mort
du roi est bien vont s'allier contre le
maréchal de gier vous nous a laissés
faire et un procès contre l'eire en
crime de lèse majesté va être organisée
juillet va perdre ce procès et même s'il
sera pas condamné à mort il sera
condamné en tout cas à la prison et à
l'exil dans son château
le résultat c'est que quelques mois plus
tard louis xii à faire un nouveau
testament et dans ce testament anne de
bretagne aura la régence de france 6 ou
12 décédé sans sans vérifier mal associé
au conseil avec louise de savoie et
georges d'amboise malheureusement pour
l'ambitieuse anne de bretagne
cette manoeuvre politique reste vaine
car la reine va mourir intentions des
pouilles on a après peu à peu construit
toute une image de militantes de
bretonne plus que française de duchesses
plus que rennes est dans la réalité
les faits sont moins prestigieux c'est
une reine de france
une reine de france n'a aucun pouvoir au
conseil elle n'y siège pas et quant à
cette idée qu'on a eu enfin cette façon
qu'on a eue de vouloir absolument
intégrer anne de bretagne dans le règne
de louis xii
ça a été d'abord par les historiens du
xviie et xviiie siècles afin de
d'excuser les erreurs de louis xii
prétendant que ce n'était pas lui qui
était responsable de sa femme qu'il aime
qu'il était trop bas dont il des troupes
amoureux et puis après au 19ème parce
que simplement elle était bretonne et
par conséquent antilles françaises dont
qu'elle voulait absolument faire se
faire détruire et enfin détruire plutôt
tout tout les projets de son épouse anne
de bretagne dont la légende historique
quelque peu gommé les traits pour
brosser à outrance le portrait d'une
reine plus pro tonnes que française n'en
reste pas moins un esprit politique
brillant su marquer la cour de france de
son empreinte permis à l'imprimerie
naissante et aux arts de rayonner sur le
royaume secondes et efficacement ses
épouses successifs parti guerroyer en
italie tout en luttant pour préserver
les libertés de son héritage breton
la reine laisse à la postérité nombre de
lettres et une importante bibliothèque
on lui doit également un magnifique
ouvrage mais grandeur d'anne de bretagne
un livre de prières inédit en forme
derbier commandité à l'enlumineur jean
bourdy champ
les trois siècles qui sépare l'avènement
de louis xii de la révolution française
désigne l'époque moderne
mais la date butoir de 14 2 192 qui voit
la découverte du nouveau monde et clôt
le moyen-âge la guerre de sens pour le
royaume de france
l'organisation de la société ses
fondements politiques et administratifs
ses valeurs morales et religieuses
trouvent leurs racines dans cette
histoire médiévale la religion demeure
le ciment d'une société gouvernée par un
monarque de droit divin devenu l'égal du
pape
anne de bretagne meurt le 9 janvier 15
elle transmet son héritage breton à sa
fille claude
qui va épouser l'impétueux françois 1er
[Musique]
oh
c'est finalement françois 1er qui va
sceller en 15 132
après six siècles d'indépendance le
rattachement de la précieuse bretagne à
la france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]